uh we got an exciting start to the 8
o'clock hour in fact because we're going
to begin with a major breakthrough for
some cancer patients now we all know
that routine testing is key to
preventing cancers in the past two
decades regular colonoscopies have
reduced the rate of deadly colorectal
cancers in people older than 50. but for
people younger than 50 colorectal cancer
is increasing and in fact it could
double by 2030. look at that chart our
doctor john lepuc is here because he's
sharing an inside look at a clinical
trial with unprecedented results results
we have not seen before and it could
help patients actually beat cancer while
avoiding the side effects of traditional
treatment do i have that right you have
that right good morning tony you know
the problem with that traditional
treatment which is chemotherapy and
radiation is it can harm normal cells
along with the cancer now this
experimental therapy helps unleash our
immune system so it can find and destroy
cancer cells without that collateral
damage we spoke to two young patients
who qualified for that trial because
their cancer had a specific mutation and
had not yet spread beyond the colon
after a three-year struggle kelly spill
finally has the wind at her back
enjoying her marriage three-year-old son
and life at the jersey shore
when did you start to notice that
something wasn't quite right about a
month before i had my little guy jace i
was going to the bathroom
i would see blood
and i went to my doctor and she pretty
much said you know you're
about to have a baby in a month things
are moving around and this is kind of
what what goes on but rectal bleeding
continued for months after spill gave
birth both her obstetrician and
internist told her she probably had
hemorrhoids and i had a gut feeling that
it was going to be cancer i just knew
a colonoscopy confirmed spill's
instincts and a specialist told her and
her mother what to expect next he let us
know that
yes i had colorectal cancer
and he told me that i most likely
wouldn't be able to carry another child
again having to go through chemo
radiation
surgery
pretty much
it would all be fried up down here
but there was a long shot chance of
avoiding all that
researchers at memorial sloan kettering
tested her tumor for a genetic mutation
that only occurs in about 5 to 10
percent of people with her type of early
stage rectal cancer oh good job she was
a match and eligible for an experimental
treatment it sounded a lot better than
chemo
i just thought
just what if that works here's how this
treatment works
some cancer cells can put the brakes on
our immune system allowing a tumor to
grow
this experimental immunotherapy is an
antibody that releases those breaks so
the immune cells can attack the cancer
dr andreas cersek led the trial at
memorial sloan kettering now we're going
to look at kelly before she started
treatment and that's all tumeric she had
that big bulky tumor this is now it's
hard not to say wow it's hard not to say
well because it's a wow yeah it really
is we weren't truly expecting this type
of response for every single patient the
tumor's gone
completely gone and how quickly
especially how quickly they responded we
haven't had to radiate anyone
or do surgery for any of our patients in
the trial all 18 patients had complete
resolution of their early rectal cancer
imtiaz hussein is one of them at age 26
even younger than kelly spill he had
similar symptoms and quickly got a
colonoscopy i think that after
four days
i got an email
saying that i was diagnosed with cancer
you got the diagnosis of cancer via an
email yes
what was that like it just shook me to
the core of my
you know
myself
like spill hussein was eligible for the
trial at memorial sloan kettering
keeping his diagnosis from his family
back in pakistan he traveled from
virginia to new york city every three
weeks for treatment but there were fewer
than 10 people in the entire planet who
had ever had it at that time right
i
did not think about that
at the beginning after four treatment i
was barely having any symptoms i got
call from my research coordinator
and she said
you don't have cancer anymore i was
crying in my car so many similarities
between our stories it's just relief
you're seeing a son after like
a year
like kind of feeling
i'm slowly
realizing what i went through
how hard it was
and now
it's like
the rainbow is here the rainbow
you i got you oh i see you we're finding
our gold now
and we need it it's time good job dude
we have good news from both patients
right now kelly spell her husband and
her son are enjoying some time road
tripping around the country in her mom's
rv and next month
imtiaz hussein
parents will travel from pakistan to
virginia for a visit and he has not seen
them in get this eight years so 18
people in this study 18 tumors gone
right everyone's going to wonder
can this apply to other types of cancer
questions yeah right and it's very
important to say it's five to ten
percent of people with this early stage
restful cancer have this specific type
of mutation that allows this treatment
to work so it's it's promising for other
people i don't want to give false hope
out there for all the people who have
different types of cancer and they're
working on getting the other say 90 of
people with cancer but that words like
breakthrough treatments all of the time
yeah and oftentimes they aren't
necessarily that but this is for that
specific type for me it was stunning so
i'm i'm a gastroenterologist okay so
i've seen many of these cancers uh
they're nasty looking you saw the first
picture they're very nasty looking to
see it completely go away yeah was i
mean you it's overused but
wow yeah that was just that was real
that was well dr cersek and i were going
wow wow it's a wow moment it isn't
amazing the pictures the side by sides
are crazy another wow moment on the on a
darker side of things we mentioned in
the introduction that for younger people
colorectal cancer is increasing why
might that be you know there are
theories we wish we knew maybe increased
sedentary lifestyle increased obesity
and one
increasingly interesting theory is the
microbiome so what is that trillions of
bacteria in our gut thousands of
different species they all interact and
certain types of species
increase your risk of having a certain
type of polyp and the kind of polyp that
can develop over time at the cancer so
we're changing our diet we're changing
lots of things in our environment and
maybe the changing microbiome is
increasing the odds of getting uh
colorectal cancer especially in these
younger people we're seeing it increase
but it's great to see you excited about
this trial yeah i am excited and i'm
excited about the future dr cersek is
formidable she's just amazing they're
going
full speed ahead with this kind of
research and i'm just i'm standing by
and watching for the next great step you
are amazing as well dr john lopez thank
you so much